hello or glad you've joined us for this
live webinar the use of flow cytometry
to identify cancer stem cells in primary
tumors and in circulation I am Judy
O'Rourke of laberd's and I'll be
moderating this session today's
educational web seminar is presented by
lab routes the leading scientific social
networking website and provider of
virtual events and webinars advancing
scientific collaboration and learning
it's brought to you by thermo Fisher
Scientific thermo Fisher is a world
leader in serving science whose mission
is to enable customers to make the world
healthier cleaner and safer
Thermo Fisher Scientific helps their
customers accelerate life sciences
research solve complex analytical
challenges improve patient diagnostics
and increase laboratory productivity for
more information please visit
www.gfi.com/webmonitor and click on the
send button questions will be answered
after the presentation to enlarge the
slide window click on the arrows at the
top right hand corner of the
presentation window if you experience
technical problems seeing or hearing the
presentation just click on the support
tab found at the top right of the
presentation window or report your
problem by typing it into the answer
question box located on the far left of
your screen this is an educational
webinar and thus offers free continuing
education credits please click on the
continuing education credits tab located
at the top right of the presentation
window and follow the process of
obtaining your credits I now present
today's speaker Bruno signs PhD dr.
signs is a Ramon and qahal researcher
with Co appointments in the Department
of Biochemistry at the Autonomous
University of Madrid the Department of
cancer biology at the instituto de
investigación co Medicus alberto Sol's
C quam and any chronic diseases and
cancer area of the Ramon and qahal
Institute for health
search doctor signs obtained his PhD in
microbiology and immunology from Tulane
University and began working on cancer
in 2011 after joining the Spanish
National Cancer Research Center as a
staff scientist he now heads the cancer
stem cells and tumor microenvironment
group focusing on the study of cancer
stem cells CFCs and the fibro
inflammatory micro environment in
pancreatic ductal adenocarcinoma his lab
is running a combined basic and
translation research program which
synergistically combines Studies on the
biology of mouse and human CSCS
including their in vivo micro
environment to enhance our understanding
of the regulatory machinery of CFCs the
group is using state-of-the-art in vitro
and in vivo systems along with acoustic
flow cytometry to better understand the
role CFCs
in cancer dr. Stein's complete bio is
found on the lab routes website dr.
Stein's will now begin his presentation
thank you very much Judy for that
presentation I'll be very happy to get
started so I've set um three basic goals
for this webinar as you can see first I
want to discuss with you all how to
identify cancer stem cells using flow
cytometry evaluate factors that should
be considered when using flow cytometry
to identify cells from tumors and from
blood and also discuss sample
preparation and choosing the correct
cancer stem cell markers to identify
these types of cells from blood and also
from tumors so as we all know 90% of
cancer deaths are a result of metastatic
disease and from a clinical or
scientific perspective one could say
that understanding these cells or the
cells that drive metastasis is
absolutely fundamental and oftentimes
the cells that drive metastases are in
fact different than the bulk tumor cells
so something we know we need to keep in
mind when we're thinking about
metastatic disease
now I think this point was best
exemplified by a study published in 2012
in the New England Journal of Medicine
by bourlingueur and all in which the
authors analyzed in sequence nine
different regions from a renal tumor
including also three metastases now this
is a very important study because they
found that the tumor itself contained
about 128 mutations but only 1/3 were
present and all the regions analyzed and
interestingly 1/4 were found in only one
single region the metastases appear to
have risen or been derived from only one
particular region which is noted here in
blue region number four and in general
the evolution of the tumor was not
linear at all but branched like a tree
and this is something we we typically
see in stem cells which also divide in a
very similar manner so in summary this
study is not only important but it
highlights the inherent heterogeneity
present within tumors and the
contribution that very few cells have on
basic the evolution or basic processes
of tumor evolutions such as metastasis
here reflected by the area for which is
the only region of the terrain that
actually gives rise to the metastasis
and secondary organs therefore
to turn the tide on this alarming
statistic of 90% of cancer deaths are
result of metastatic disease I think we
really need to better understand the
tumor at the cellular level and also
develop techniques to differentiate all
the essential cellular players involved
not only in process of tumor formation
but also in the process of metastasis
now it's been known for the past two
decades that cancer stem cells are CSCS
play a very important role in metastasis
these cells represent a very rare and
small subpopulation of cells within the
tumor that have area that are highly
tumorigenic and have stem-like
properties to date they've been
identified in just about all solid
tumors and they are believed to be
drivers of for example resistance to
therapy disease relapse and in more most
importantly metastasis mediated by
cancer stem cells actually go into
circulation which we refer to as
circulating cancer stem cells
now the cancer stem cell concept as as
as a whole is not a very new concept as
early as 1855 there were reports
multiple studies reporting stem like
cells in different cancers and we can
think of rudolf virchow and later a
julius cone Haim as the grandfather's of
the cancer stem cell concept with which
they both proposed on the basis of
observed similarities between fetal
tissue and cancer that cancer actually
developed or developed in in the past
from activation of dormant embryonic
tissue remnants we now know this is not
true but it was the first that we used
were the first studies linking a
possibility possible link between cancer
and embryonic tissue or cancer stem
cells since then it took about 100 years
to officially isolate and identify
cancer stem cells and this was due to
the efforts of John [ __ ] colleagues
in 1994 where they were for the first
time were able to isolate and purify
cancer stem cells from acute myeloid
leukemia AML now this advanced our this
this a very important discovery was
based on the availability of two
important techniques or methodologies on
the one hand the availability of immuno
compromised mice which is very important
for the for the capacity to implant
human cells into a small animal model
and also the advent and the availability
of flow cytometry specifically
fluorescents associated cell sorting
both of these techniques allow the
researchers to first isolate the cells
of interest and then implant those cells
and new mice to test their tumor genetic
capacity so you can see here on the
right one one of the experiments and
figures from their paper you can see
that the author's isolated both cd34
negative and cd34 positive AML cells via
flow cytometry using antibodies against
cd34 you can see very nicely that only
the cd34 positive population are the
cells that are tumorigenic or have the
capacity to form tumors in
immunocompromised mice they went one
step further and also use cd38 and
isolated both cd34 positive cd38
positives
and cd34 positive cd38 negative cells
and it was the latter population xxx
cd34 positive cd38 negative cells that
were the tumor genic cells so this also
showed that within the cancer stem cell
population there's a hierarchy and
multiple sometimes multiple cell surface
markers need to be used to identify
these very rare and tumor genic cells
now since then cancer stem cells have
been identified in just about all solid
tumors as you can see here in liver
cancer in pancreatic cancer and in
multiple other solid organs it's
important to note that today it is well
accepted that cancer stem cells are the
root of the tumor and must be eliminated
in to ensure tumor eradication
now cancer stem cells maintain their
tumors or the tumor heterogeneity and
they promote chemo resistance and
metastasis due to their stem-like
properties so if we look and we refer to
the system like properties because if we
look within these cells specifically at
the molecular level we often find
pathways activated that we tend to find
activated and functional in stem cells
so if we look in within a cancer stem
cell we can find wind signaling active
sonic sonic headed Hedgehog signaling
active not signaling active and nodal
signaling active Hippo pathways active
in these cells which are pathways that
we tend to find active in cancer stem
cells and therefore we often refer to
these cells as stem like cells or cancer
stem cells
in addition the
so resides within a very complex niche
within the tumor much like a stem cell
resides within its niche and you can see
this here shown on the left the tumour
nature the cancer stem cell niche that
receives cues or information from its
niche the niche provides information
that promotes a symmetric division of
cancer stem cells to give rise to for
example transient hybrid cancer cells or
or it which then will give rise to more
differentiated tumor cells within the
tumor stroma or the bulk tumor
or another either the more differentiate
cells the transient hybrid cancer cells
or even the cancer stem cell itself can
go into circulation once in circulation
they can make their way to secondary
organs for example the liver and
establishment asta sees in these organs
now circulation is a very difficult
environment for these cells so they have
to fall on one hand survive apoptosis
and on the other hand up regulate
factors or lichens or receptors that
will make them invisible to the immune
system basically promoting immune
evasion it's important to note however
or in addition that wrote that the
relatively new concept of plasticity
when we talk about the cancer stem cell
concept whereby a non cancer stem cell
for example can differentiate into a
cancer stem cell if the cancer compar
cancer stem cell compartment is
compromised so this in upon in addition
makes this situation or this concept
even more complex and targeting
therefore the cancer stem cell may not
always be as as efficient as we as we
have previously thought understanding
that transient hybrid cells can at some
time or another via plasticity take
their place
thus since the mature
of cancer patients died from metastasis
what is needed in my opinion our methods
to detect those cells that actually
caused metastasis be to either
circulating tumor cells or in this case
and in this specifically for this
webinar the identification in the study
of circulating cancer stem cells
in my laboratory we study circulating
tumor cells cancer stem cells and
circulating cancer stem cells in the
context of pancreatic ductal
adenocarcinoma P doc as I refer to it as
is a malignant neoplasm of the exocrine
pancreas it's currently the fourth most
frequent cause of cancer-related death
and it's projected to become the second
most frequent cause of cancer-related
death by 2030 it is currently the
deadliest form of cancer
with a five-year survival rate of less
than seven percent pancreatic tumors are
highly resistant to chemo and readit
radiotherapy and unfortunately Pedic is
usually diagnosed at a very late stage
once that once the subject our patients
have metastases due to a lack of early
symptoms and reliable and imaging
methods so this is a terrible disease
and unfortunately there are no reliable
or effective treatments to treat
pancreatic cancer so any advances in
understanding this disease are very much
welcomed
so now let's move on to how cancer stem
cells can be identified this is an
important point especially when you want
to study a disease or a tumor that is
meaty to by cancer stem cells and for
this webinar what we will discuss is how
can cancer stem cells be identified
using flow cytometry
now the main method for identifying
cancer stem cells has been and still is
flow cytometry which takes the advantage
of cell surface markers expressed on the
cancer stem cell surface the most common
cancer stem cells markers used for
pancreatic cancer are shown here in this
diagram for example epoch M cd133 cd44
and cxcr4 common markers used to
identify and isolate pancreatic cancer
stem cells of course iceland cancer stem
cells is not trivial and it's extremely
difficult and oftentimes it depends
primarily on the use of antibodies that
detect cell surface markers that are
sometimes not exclusively expressed on
cancer stem cells
you
reason we actually set out to identify
new cancer stem cell markers that could
be identified primarily via flow
cytometry but independent of the use of
antibodies so in 2014 we publish a study
may Nature Methods describe it a new
cancer stem cell inherent marker that we
termed autofluorescence as you can see
here the publication what we did is we
use primary patient-derived xenograft
cultures from Pedic samples and we
observed in these cultures a very
discreet green vesicles in our primary
cultures as you can see here in the
first figure on the right interestingly
when these cultures were called when
these cells were cultured in conditions
that enriched for cancer stem cells
known as spheres what we saw repeatedly
was an increase in this autofluorescence
at the microscopic level the
autofluorescence was restricted to
vesicles covered in the ATP transporter
a BCG tube as you can see here on the
left and come focal image using a BCG to
fuse to M sherry to detect its location
and its localization within the cell and
the auto fluorescence had a very
specific excitation and emission spectra
which is very different than for example
GFP most importantly we could identify
an isolate these cells using flow
cytometry without the need for
antibodies so you can see here in these
blue side and metric plots and it here
in cultures we can detect a percentage
of cells that are Auto fluorescent and
that percentage of cells increases when
we put the cells in conditions that
promote the enrichment of cancer stem
cells for example providing these cells
and conditions of sphere formation
okay and what we're also able to confirm
is that these cancer stem cells auto
flesh and cancer stem cells upon
injection in new mice were always more
tumorigenic than the non auto porcine
cancer stem cells
a b a b c g to accumulation on the
membrane of these vesicles was only
observed in on a forest and positive
cells as you can see here on the right
auto flores and positive cells that were
sorted in auto parts and negative cells
that were sorted we only saw the
accumulation of ABC g2 in the vesicles
when in the cells that were Auto
fluorescent we later learned that the
substance accumulated in these vesicles
was actually nothing more than that the
naturally fluoresce in vitamin
riboflavin riboflavin naturally
fluorescence at very high concentrations
value provide by flavin can also pass
membranes via the present or via the the
aid of a BCG to transporters so it was
not illogical that we would have
riboflavin accumulation in vesicles that
are coated in ABC g2
now since this publication we've
extended our analyses of auto flesh and
cancer stem cells to more tumors as a
means primarily determine determining
whether cancer stem cell whether we can
determine the cancer stem cell load and
freshly respected tumors so in
collaboration with local hospitals in
the area
we've analyzed 92 tumors to date and
we've been able to
see that we've been able to detect
autofluorescence cancer stem cells in a
large number of these tumors
interestingly our ability to detect auto
force and cancer stem cells is primarily
restricted to tumors of the
gastrointestinal tract for example colon
pancreas stomach rectum gastric and
liver cancers so this also highlights
the fact that perhaps this cancer stem
cell marker autofluorescence may be
something unique to gastrointestinal
tumors
now importantly these cells that we've
been able to identify and fresh leavers
like the tumors can also be isolated via
flow cytometry and culture and envy in
vitro as shown here this is subject 57
which is a rectum cancer we were able to
identify the auto parts and cancer stem
cells isolate these cells and put these
cells in culture and you can see we were
able to establish a culture and these
cultures maintained their auto
fluorescent vesicles
we're also able to inject these cells in
small animal models so triggers for
example such as zebrafish
so shown here are zebrafish injected
with Auto fluorescent positive cells and
all our auto course negative cells
isolated from a colon cancer sample in
the yolk sac and then we were able to
evaluate their distribution one hundred
and forty four hours post injection you
can see that the cells the Auto percent
negative cells that were injected were
no longer present 144 hours post
injection while the auto Forest and
positive cells that we injected we're
still present within the within the
zebrafish and had begin to migrate and
expand and extend themselves within the
zebrafish model
now while flu Saitama
a powerful tool for identifying cell
populations many factors should be
considered especially when working with
rare subpopulations of cells such as
cancer stem cells and even more scarce
populations such as circulating cancer
stem cells in blood for the purpose of
this webinar I would like to focus on
the latter which are circulating cancer
stem cells in blood but the same
considerations I'm going to discuss can
be applied to cancer stem cells from
tumor samples or also from cell lines
now when we talk about circulating
cancer stem cells we tend to lump this
into the category of circulating tumor
cells and detecting circulating tumor
cells has been very very challenging
process the existing paradigm states
that circulating tumor cells can be can
be isolated or detected based on the
expression of cell surface markers also
by filtration by size other techniques
I've used density separation to isolate
and detect circulating tumor cells and
also for example white blood cells a
negative selection analysis so basically
eliminating the white blood cells and
all the red blood cells and only
remaining with the non immune cells to
isolate circulating tumor cells from
blood samples
to do this however specialized platforms
and instruments are needed for example
the very Excel search system is one
platform that is commonly used and
fda-approved for certain types of
cancers and also other other platforms
exist these exclusive and specialized
platforms however are very cost
prohibitive in some settings also CPC is
detected using these platforms used
antibodies against for example app cam
which is an epithelial marker or
cytokeratins which you could think are
likely not prison on cells that have
undergone EMT or or assumed a more
mesenchymal like state so maybe some of
these antibodies that are exclusive to
these platforms are not specific for the
circulating tumor cell population also
these platforms are not designed to
isolate or detect cell clumps or
aggregates so this also reduces our
capacity to detect circulating tumor
cells or certain circulating cancer stem
cells that may travel as aggregates with
support cells which is something that
the literature is now referring to as a
very likely possibility for circulating
tumor cells
that being said obviously there is there
is room for improvement so therefore we
believe that a flow cytometry based
approach is the best option for
identifying circulating tumor cells and
circulating cancer stem cells however
you can see here on the right
traditional hydrodynamic focusing which
is the traditional methodology used for
flow cytometry and using using this
hydrodynamic focusing cells are not
aligned in a continuous stream resulting
in many events be lost at the time of
sample event acquisition now this is
your tends not to be problematic if the
population you're looking for is is
present in very high percentages but
when you're looking for a very rare
small population of cells this can
reduce your ability or the precision or
your ability to detect this very small
population so to improve upon this we
have moved to a qaq acoustic acoustic
focusing base cytometry using the thermo
Fisher Scientific attune NXT site ometer
that uses an acoustically focused sample
stream to align cells for a better
position and increase detection of very
rare events which is the population
which is a type of cell population that
we are looking for
now again going back to the existing
platforms another another inconvenience
is that most platforms implement an
initial step to eliminate immune cells
so we have to ask the question is that
if circulating tumor cells and
circulating cancerous dumps are
traveling in circulation which support
cells maybe some of those support cells
are actually immune cells and if we
implement an initial step to eliminate
immune cells we might be losing those
circulating tumor cells or the
circulating cancer stem cells also some
of the results from these platforms are
inconclusive
sometimes a variable and the procedure
is time consuming for example detecting
circulating tumor cells and pancreatic
cancer patient sample is extremely
challenging and the very dec system has
not proven beneficial for detecting CPCs
and PTAC patients
so therefore I think what we need are
more specific CPC markers to detect
circulating tumor cells and circulating
cancer stem cells as well as newer
faster and easier methods of detection
so regarding previous point number four
when I mentioned that the elimination of
immune cells from the sample may
compromise our ability to detect
circulating tumor cells or circling
cancerous down stem cells as more
studies are indicating that these that
these types of circulating cells
actually exist in circulation as
aggregates with immune cells what we've
what we've tried to do is as is take
information from the literature and
apply this to our platform so there have
been some very nice recent studies for
example study by atoms in all published
in 2014 in PNAS that actually suggests
that circulating tumor cells do
circulate with immune cells so in this
study in particular what the group what
the authors observed was that
circulating tumor cells were actually
fused to macrophages and the cells in
circulation expressed both epithelial
cell markers you can see here AB cam
positive side of keratin positive and at
the same time expressed immune cell
markers for example cd45 so they were
able to identify circulating tumor cells
that were actually expressed markers
also present on immune cells and they
suggested that these cells were actually
giant circulating giant macrophages that
had been fused with circulating tumor
cells
now the question remains this is this a
very radical concept in fact it's not if
we think if we go in if we take a look
at many of the studies performing the
calm beliefs lab at Albert Albert
Einstein University they've been
studying for years how macrophages are
necessary for the inter is a ssin of
circulating tumor cells essentially what
they have shown is that macrophages
promote tumor cell dissemination to
secondary organs are absolutely
necessary for the tumor cell to enter
into circulation now whether or not this
is done via fusion process or whether or
not the macrophage just just is along
for the ride is still yet to be
determined in addition we have shown
that one way that macrophages may also
promote circulation is actually between
promote epithelial mesenchymal
transition or EMT via secreted factors
so using here in this mystic example
experiment we have used patient-derived
xenograft primary cultures and we
treated them with M two polarized
macrophage condition medium
and what we're able to what we saw is a
clear mesenchymal transition mediated by
macrophage secreted factors as early as
eight days and as late as 25 days
treating our primary cultures with
macrophage condition medium
so our working model is that Tam's or
tumor associated macrophages that are
present in the tumor actually promote
cancer stem cell dissemination by
promoting epithelial to mesenchymal
transition or EMT via secreted factors
or perhaps also by directly interacting
with cancer stem cells or cancer cells
to promote this perfusion event the
latter is actually this idea of Tam's
promoting cancer stem cells
dissemination is actually biologically
relevant in the case of pancreatic
cancer as CD 163 positive macrophages or
Tam's are the main immune cell
infiltrate present in PTAC you can see
this here in this immunity stir chemical
staining of a patient of a pancreatic
tumor you can see here the the massive
infiltration of c d 163 positive
macrophages we also see in blood samples
so here we have a sample from a healthy
control we can see a a monocyte
macrophage population of about 1.2
percent however when we look at the same
macrophage monocyte population in blood
from minused attic pancreatic cancer
sample we see about a three-fold
increase in the percentage of these
cells present in in circulation now if
we look specifically at this population
and we use a marker for m2 macrophages
or or Tam's tumor associated macrophages
here in this example we're using c d 163
and via flow cytometry what we see is
that we see a forty four point six
percent of the monocyte macrophages are
c d 163 positive indicating that there
is an increase in m2 or 10 like
macrophages in circulation which are
likely coming from the primary tumor
so the hypothesis is that macrophages
promote cancer stem cell dissemination a
mentor is a ssin circulation and
facilitate their their extravasation to
secondary organs in order to form
metastases
now this hypothesis was recently
supported by a publication in 2017 by
Clausen and all where they observe
fusion between circulating tumor cells
and Tam's as shown here with a PD Excel
cell marker which is Ald h1 and a
macrophage marker here they use cd68 and
you can see that the cells that they
were able to isolate from from blood
samples were both ALDH one positive and
cd68 positive again indicating that
perhaps a fusion event between tumor
associated macrophages and circulating
tumor cells
basically the same approach but applied
it to a flow cytometry platform so we
use CD 163 and our autofluorescence as
our markers to detect double positive
cells and you can see here in sample 38
we were able to detect the double
positive population 3.2 4% of the cells
were both positive for art of
fluorescence and positive for its CD 163
and when we isolated this population we
observe that these cells could form
spheres in vitro these spheres also
retain their autofluorescence phenotype
they were also able to form tumors and
nude mice metastases metastasized to the
liver following Teta and following tail
vein is in injection and here's shown on
the right is a table showing that CD 163
positive macrophages increase in pH
samples compared to healthy samples and
we also see that an increase in P deck
and double positive cells both positive
for autofluorescence and positive for CD
163 in our P deck samples
so these data indicate that these Tam
CTC few cells could be used to develop a
liquid biopsy assay
feasible screening liquid biopsy assay
we are now exclusively using
acoustic-based cytometry which allows
for prop more precision and the ability
to detect these very rare events when we
compare this type of cytometry to more
conventional cytometry or did a
traditional hydrodynamic focusing
cytometry with acoustic cytometry were
able to detect more events sometimes
anywhere from three to five percent
three or five times more events than we
were able to detect using traditional
hydra hydrodynamic based
focusing so here in this slide is an
example of the detection limits of this
approach
so in this success in this experiment
what we used was fixed blood samples and
we spiked our fixed blood samples with
pancreatic ductal adenocarcinoma cells
and we analyzed on the attune NXT
cytometry using the violet laser and in
addition together with the no wash no
lights filter set the gate on nucleus
cells without lysine the sample so the
no wash no life filter set allows one to
gate directly on nucleated cells
therefore the sample does not need to be
lice and the sample does not need to be
washed you can directly fix the sample
or not fix the sample add your
antibodies to the blood and detect your
your your cell target without having to
introduce extra variables such as lysine
red blood cells which can damage your
cells as well and the multiple number of
washing steps that can reduce your
ability to detect cells and you can
actually lose some of the very rare
cells that you're that you're trying to
detect
so which you can see here within the
population we detected fm+ PD excels
with high efficiency and precision
demonstrating the utility of this
approach and the first column you can
see here this is blood where no Pedic
cells were introduced and we have 0%
detection of epic am+ Pedic cells and
then we did delusions from 10 to the 6
down to 10 to the 3rd and were able to
identify very well for when we were able
when we should have detected to 200,000
cells were able to detect 106,000 cells
20 thousand cells 11,000 cells 2,000
cells 1,300 cells and 200 cells we also
were able to detect in very 200 cells
were able to detect 98 cells showing
very well the the utility of this
approach the precision and the
efficiency using the attune NXT
cytometer
so our main hype
is therefore is that circulating cancer
stem cells enter into circulation
accompanied by tumor promoting
macrophages and we want to apply this
methodology to primary samples usually
using CD 163 as our marker for the tumor
associated macrophages and our two
markers for the cancer stem cells and
tumor cells would be autofluorescence
and ebb cam respectively
using the attune NXT no Washington lysis
filter gaining strategy we can see here
the nucleus cells which are present
within the gate within that population
we can see very nicely the distribution
of the immune cells granulocytes T cells
monocytes etc and then within this
population we can specifically detect
the c d 163 positive or tumor associated
macrophages using antibodies against c d
163
as you can see here in this analysis
here we have a healthy sample and using
UN within the 150-160 positive
population we were not able to detect
epic and positive cells nor Auto for us
themselves in this healthy sample
however if you look at the pancreatic
cancer simple we're able to detect very
nicely within the CD 163 positive
population 2.1 / 2 point 1 8 percent of
the cells at our epoch am positive and
28.6% of the cells that are out of
forest and positive the indicating that
our doctor our target population this
double positive population is present in
pancreatic cancer samples but not in
healthy samples
now if we look here in this analysis we
can see that which is very interesting
those samples with the highest number
numbers of double positive cells which
are indicated here with the red bars are
the SAR correlate very well to lower
overall survival and lower
progression-free survival so those
samples were we're able to detect high
percentages of this double positive
population these samples correlated very
well to low overall survival which is
basically we're trying to look for is a
marker that will allow us to predict
perhaps overall survival or
progression-free survival
vision i cytometry base liquid biopsy
assay for the detection of circulating
tumor cells that could be used for
countless purposes and hospitals with
the main goal however of advancing
personalized medicine options for cancer
subjects so we ambitions as technology
being used for example for quantifying
circulating tumor cells or circulating
cancer stem cells before and after
treatment to determine drug efficacy or
chemotherapy efficacy we also envision
that this sort of platform could be used
for monitoring circulating tumor cell or
circulating cancer stem cell populations
post surgical intervention and perhaps
assessing the appearance of circulating
tumor cells or circulating cancer stem
cells as a predictive marker of cancer
development or reappearance during
remission
as with with all platforms are all
assays sample preparation and choosing
the right panel markers is very
important and needs to be empirically
determined by each user our workflow is
very specific to the type of tumor we
work within the type of cancer stem
cells we work with and then tumor and
the cancer stem cell markers that we
have chosen it's important that for
sample preparation and choosing the
cancer stem cell markers that each tumor
may be different what I will present
here is our workflow and the
requirements and the requirements and
the preparations that that our samples
undergo for our analyses however it's
highly recommended that each user that
develops a similar liquid liquid biopsy
assay empirically determine their
conditions so our samples come from the
hospitals and the samples are acquired
from our patient population of interest
these samples are for example blood
samples are correct collected in various
different types of blood collection
tubes for example heparin tubes or EDTA
tubes and the nice thing about our
platform is that you can choose whether
or not to fix the cells or not fix the
cells if you choose to fix the cells we
have been using the transfix cellular
antigen stabilizing reagent which works
very well for stabilizing the antigens
on the cells and the antigens are
actually stable for up to 10 days at
four degrees Celsius now as I mentioned
before we take these samples and we run
them through the TuneIn xt site ometer
we do what we call a sample cleanup by
using the violet laser in conjunction
with the no wash no lights filter kit
which allows us to gate them directly on
the nucleated cells and then this is the
population of interest so no need to
lyse the cells no need to wash we can
immediately go to the nucleus cells and
determine whether or not ours are
circulating tumor cells or circulating
cancer stem cells are within the
nucleated population if we don't fix
ourselves and what we tend to do is also
add a dead cell exclusion marker so that
we think food all dead cells and focus
just on the live nucleated cells of
course you have to choose your m2 by use
of choice for here for example
antibodies that can be used to to
directly mark your immune cells of
interest and if Tam's or tumor
associated macrophages are of interest
we tend to use the mutagen antibodies
against CD 45 and CD 163 however other
markers can be added markers for myeloid
cells markers for t-cells etc and of
course you have to choose which cancer
stem cell markers are appropriate for
your tumor type and for your conditions
and whether or not you are I didn't want
to identify circulating cancer stem
cells or cancer stem cells directly from
tumors so for example you could use F
cam to identify those epithelial cells
in blood samples pan-slavic keratin for
example and of course we also include
our autofluorescence marker
and once the thing has been performed we
can run these samples very efficiently
and thoroughly through via toon and XP
site ometer we do a multi color analysis
and a quantification you can actually
quantify the number of events or the
number of of ctcs or circulating cancer
stem cells using account bright absolute
counting beats and in the end obviously
including your healthy samples together
with your your your experimental samples
will allow you to gain confidence in
your results and to compare the signal
you receive from the from the
experimental sample compared to the
healthy sample and with that I would
like to thank you all for your attention
I would be more than happy to further
explain any points in the presentation
or to answer any questions thank you dr.
science for your presentation quick
reminder for our audience on how to
submit questions simply type them into
the drop down box located on the far
left of your presentation window labeled
ask a question and click on the send
button
dr. signs will answer as many questions
as time permits the first question is
can you combine the autofluorescence
with well-known cell surface markers to
increase the ability to detect cancer
stem cells from tumors or from blood so
you can definitely you can definitely
combine the autofluorescence marker with
any marker of interest and the
literature is you read in literature I
think just about every month a new
cancer stem cell marker is being
identified so the ease of the
autofluorescence
is that is antibody independent which
then allows you to include more
antibodies without having issues of
isotope controls etc the only limitation
however is your channel for for green
fluorescent has been occupied by the
auto fluorescence but you can definitely
combine other markers based on the
number of lasers you have especially if
you use the violet laser then you have a
innovative larger gambit of of
antibodies that can be included thank
you why do cancer stem cells accumulate
riboflavin in these vesicles and do you
think there is a biological benefit
that's an excellent question why they
accumulate the riboflavin on at the
biological level or at the mechanistic
level we know they accumulated because
they over express a b c g2 on their on
the surface of these vesicles so
naturally riboflavin is a is Allah is
likened for the ABCD transporter so it
will be it will pass through the
membranes that have this transporter and
the fact that the vesicles overexpress
them and the natural result is that
accumulation within the vesicles now
whether or not this accumulation of
riboflavin has any sort of biological
benefit that I think we still do not
know obviously riboflavin have as many
biological functions it's a precursor
for the flavor of protein so it may be
that the cancer stem cells are acutely
accumulating riboflavin to ensure the
the production or the availability of
flavor proteins which which function in
many different biological processes but
I think that that question is still is
still open and on the insert thank you
next one is if there one universal
marker that could detect all the cancer
stem cells subpopulations across all
tumor entities that would be fantastic I
and I wish it is nice that the that the
autofluorescence biomarker it seems to
be a very good marker for identifying
cancer stem cells of gastrointestinal
origins the only thing I would be
cautious to say is that do there exist
cancer stem cells that are not Auto
fluorescent positive perhaps and most
likely do there do there exist cancer
stem cells that Express markers that we
have yet to identify probably so I think
if we limit ourselves to one marker we
are just getting a glimpse of the cancer
stem cell population on that expresses
that marker and we also should always
keep in mind that there are other cancer
stem cell populations that probably
Express other markers that if we don't
use those markers we're losing that
information as well
thank you looks like we have time for
one more question what do you recommend
for a number of sales required for
analysis
so from I can turn into parts from from
primary tumors and from blood samples
from primary tumors I would suggest at
least if it's possible anywhere from
five to ten million cells it's a good
amount of cells to do an analysis for
cancer stem cell percentages we have to
keep in mind that depending on the tumor
type that you're studying the cancer
stem cell population can be anywhere
from a 0.5% to 5% to 10% so I think that
nisa based on those percentages you can
extrapolate on the number of cells that
you would you will need for merely
detecting the cells by flow cytometry
you can obviously reduce those numbers
of cells and obviously with the tune in
XP cytometry you gain greater confidence
and imprecision because you're able to
capture each and area event if you're
using traditional Thurman Zion the
traditional cytometry you might want to
increase those numbers from blood
samples a good starting volume is about
5 ml of blood which can be used and
marked and analyzed as mentioned in this
presentation I would like to once again
thank dr. Stein's for his presentation
do you have any final comments
no I would like to thank the opportunity
to present our work and our the the
experiments and me and the research that
we're doing in our laboratory of course
thank also Thermo Fisher Scientific for
this opportunity and and you all for
your attention for that I'd like to
thank the audience for joining us today
and for their interesting questions
questions we do not have time for today
will be addressed by the speaker via the
contact information you provided at the
time of registration we would like to
thank our sponsor Thermo Fisher
Scientific for underwriting today's
educational webcast this webcast can be
viewed on-demand through June 2019
labret will alert you via email when
it's available for replay we encourage
you to share that email with your
colleagues who may have missed today's
live event until next time goodbye